Як і в попередні роки,
церемонія вшанування жертв катастрофи
рейсу МН17 розпочалася
із зачитування імен рідними та друзями загиблих.
На третю річницю трагедії
відкрили масштабний Національний Монумент,
територія якого сягає двох гектарів.
Комплекс розташований
за 15 кілометрів від Амстердамського аеропорту "Схіпгол".
Саме звідси вилетів рейс МН17.
Король Нідерландів Віллем-Олександр
та королева Максима разом з дітьми сусіднього селища
поклали перші квіти до меморіалу,
символічно відкривши монумент.
"Live on - Життя триває" –
лейтмотив цьогорічної церемонії вшанування пам'яті.
Ця ідея відображена і в задумі меморіалу.
"Ліс пам'яті" – таку концепцію
Національного Монументу MH17
затвердили рідні загиблих у авіакатастрофі.
Тут, посеред поля, посадили 298 дерев –
саме стільки пасажирів перебувало на борту літака.
Кожне дерево носить ім'я та прізвище
конкретної людини і символізує душу,
яка продовжує жити.
Форму усього меморіального комплексу
- зігнуту траурну стрічку - можна побачити
лише з висоти пташиного польоту.
Перші земляні роботи почалися тут
у грудні 2016 року.
Привезли родючий чорнозем.
Згодом почистили і розширили водний  канал поруч.
Від нього проклали систему для індивідуального поливу дерев.
Наступний етап -
бетонування фундаменту для центральної частини монументу.
Найскладніше було привезти і встановити у центрі комплексу
16-тонний зігнутий лист заліза
завдовжки 16  і висотою чотири метри.
Я прийшов сюди вшанувати пам'ять свого брата,
його дружини та їхнього сина,
які загинули в катастрофі MH17.
Одна компанія надала нам дерева, інша - виділила землю.
Загалом багато компаній-спонсорів
допомогли нам в той чи інший спосіб.
Перше дерево на честь командира екіпажу лайнера
посадили міністр закордонних справ Нідерландів,
посол Малайзії і президент Малазійських авіаліній.
Решту дерев саджали родини загиблих.
Окрім того, що дерева висаджені
у формі траурної стрічки, вони ще й
розташовані амфітеатром,
тож з будь-якої точки меморіалу видно його центральну частину.
За задумом контемпорарі-арт художника Рональда Вестергуіза,
іржавий лист заліза – символ тягаря втрати
і темряви смутку,
відполірований неіржавіючий метал –
символ променя світла, який вселяє надію.
І лише з висоти пташиного польоту видно,
що ці абстрактні, якщо на них дивитися з землі,
шматки металу утворюють око.
Око в центрі символізує надію і співчуття.
Співчуття, бо це око завжди дивиться на небо.
Але залишається місце і для надії.
Світло, яке спадає з неба на нас, дає благословенну надію нам,
родичам загиблих, родичам пасажирів рейсу MH17.
З відкриттям монументу тепер з'явився
потужний матеріальний об'єкт, який нагадує живим,
що їх обов'язок перед загиблими -
довести до кінця справу покарання у суді винних
у масовому вбивсті.
А для тих, хто творив зло і знає, що вони відповідальні
за смерть 298  людей, центральна частина
нідерландського Національного Меморіалу МН17
може стати символом всевидючого ока,
від якого неможливо приховати свої діяння.